hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome Checkmate Paul Murphy played
without his rook and A1 against his
uncle uh this is the game E4 E5 Knight
to F3 Knight to C6 with D4 sort of the
scotch but not really because white is
already starting with a handicap Bishop
to B4 check C3 captures and here morphe
castles we have captors Bishop captures
going after G7 Bishop blocks and now
Pawn to E5 D6 uh we rooked the E1 and
here uh La carpentia cap captures we
have Knight captures on E5 and queen
captures on D1 morphe plays Bishop
captures an F7 with check King E7 Knight
to G6 with a double check from the
knight in The Rook King captures and
Knight captures and h8 is Checkmate from
The Rook bishop and Knight on h8 that's
it that's the game hope you enjoyed it
see you soon